yeah dude hot dogs is a lot of pig
butthole hot dogs we were talking about
baloney same thing
what well I've seen how hot dogs are
made it doesn't look good hot dogs and
baloney but I will forever always at a
ball game eat a hot dog
yeah man I'm gonna catch up to Dodger
Stadium why not because they're [__]
garbage what those Dodger Dogs yeah we
went to L.A we went to Dodger games for
a long [__] time and I'm Gonna Catch
[__] for this from people I know from
other Dodger fans but look other Dodger
fans just a Dodger fan no I just mean
like Dodger fans yeah I'm not a Dodger
fan go Sox don't forget 2018 they never
will that should have been a sweep also
anywho
um the Dodger dogs are
awful they're terrible there's like the
the hot dog doesn't taste good like if
you compare it to a Fenway Frank it's
the best [__] thing I've ever had in
Montana yeah but you don't know how to
eat a hot dog anyways because you don't
put mustard on your hot dogs no I don't
I put ketchup Mayo onions what are you
eight why ketchup on a hot dog what are
you four years ketchup Mayo onions we've
talked about this grilled veggies what
else do you want that sounds like an
amazing hot dog Mayo onions
keep going now grilled veggies real
veggies yeah bacon if you want it
mustard no relish nope
period
you picked the worst two topics for a
hot dog
which hot dog do you pick
mustard and relish or any other hot dog
no that's not what you said okay ketchup
Mayo
onions and grilled veggies and if that's
give us a bacon wrapped one you could do
that too no bacon wrap throws everything
out the window because there's bacon so
let's just stick with but think about it
if you do bacon wrapped and you still
put your toppings or my toppings mine's
way better
[Music]
that I get
more positive from mine and it'll be age
too yeah because your own human people
or old ass people they're grown like not
four-year-olds who dip their cut up hot
dogs into ketchup while they watch PAW
Patrol hey hey cut up hot dogs tastes
good okay or sausage sausage dipped in
anything is good I like sausage like
regular saucers they're talking about
right now you went from bologna to hot
sauce so I went from hot dog to sausage
that was [__] a close enough
digression I'm saying I'm saying
sausages are good and by the way a
sausage with mustard
you can't ever saw a [__] sausage in
a bun with ketchup no you don't
no you don't you don't eat with ketchup
or mustard
what a sausage in a bun is straight up
mustard onions
[__] [__] nope raised you Jimmy
[__]
you did
this is I don't think we've ever been so
far apart on something
yeah look mustard on anything is
terrible yo dude you can't put ketchup
in potato salad you can put mustard
there yeah but why would you put mustard
in it you can't listen when you're
cooking a chicken or chicken breast you
can put some mustard on there you can
put ketchup on there
it doesn't mean it taste good you can
you can technically put it on there it
doesn't taste good
like you could technically baste the
ribs you would make in ketchup what a
great example but mustard on the ribs
you're by the way you're welcome but it
doesn't taste like mustard because if it
tastes like mustard it would taste like
[__] so no you know what it tastes like
not mustard no but mustard helps things
taste better
that's the whole point no because it's
not only mustard on ribs there's a [__]
ton of seasoning but you know it's not
you know when it's brown sugar you know
what is it Ketchup yeah but it's also
you know what it's not that much mustard
[__] ketchup mustard is still trash
okay good comeback yeah
um good time I can't wait for me to win
are we batting 100
okay so we're about 100 that my hot dog
will beat your hot dog
a hundred a hundred and we will count
the comments on YouTube
no you don't get to go all you get to be
one place
why are you picking all of them well
because I why not just add them all up
but these are all love people that are
listening and watching
okay YouTube Instagram Tick Tock okay
sit up get in the frame
foreign
the [__] worst lunch meat you could
have but it's not really a meat it's the
worst whatever you could have yeah it's
like a lunch lunch it's like a lunch
thing item it's an item put your cup
baloney meat it's a lot of different
types of meat product plus other [__]
yeah it's meat product plus is what they
should call it
that's what it is I don't really know
what it is it's that yeah okay fair
enough yeah yeah it's a lot of like
probably Pig butthole